welcome back so now we're going to take
a diversion into the Laplace transform
domain and transfer functions because
this is going to help us to assess
things like performance and robustness
of our closed loop controlled systems
okay so we're going to tie this back in
with what we've learned from optimal
control with regulators and column and
filters later but for now what we're
going to do is move away from the state
space or ordinary differential equation
formulation and we're going to move
towards transfer functions so in general
I guess the way I like to think about a
system that I want to control so maybe
this is my inverted pendulum on a cart
or maybe do this as a car that I'm
trying to drive or an airplane or
something like that is abstractly it's a
system that takes inputs and give some
measurement outputs why and I might or
might not know what's going on under the
hood here I might or might not know what
the full state X is or what the dynamics
are so for example if I don't know what
happens between you and why I might have
to build a model from data that's
something we'll talk about later its
system identification but in general we
think of this map from u to Y as just
some function that moves from u to Y and
we call this a transfer function and
sometimes we're going to call this
transfer function G sometimes we'll call
it P there's a few different notations
out there but we're going to say that
this is a transfer function transfer
function G and so this transfer function
there are essentially four linear
systems at least there are these three
equivalent representations so I want to
write this down this is really important
so there are three equivalent
representations
for linear systems and this is really
important that we're talking about
linear systems okay and these three
representations are as follows so on the
one hand we have our state space okay
and maybe I'll keep it interesting with
some more colors so we have state space
that's this one this is essentially our
OD e X dot equals ax plus bu y equals CX
okay in addition to state space we have
our frequency domain or our transfer
function so I'm going to draw that over
here I'm going to say we have our
frequency domain okay and this would be
our transfer function G so G of s and
I'm going to write down what it is but
I'll derive it for you later so this is
s is a Laplace transform variable and G
of s is if this is my system it would be
C times this Laplace transform variable
si minus a inverse times B okay so this
is the expression in the frequency
domain this is my transfer function and
there's one other equivalent
representation which is essentially in
the time domain okay I'm going to write
it up here maybe in blue we have the
time domain representation in terms of
what's known as the impulse response
okay and what I'm going to show you is
that these are all equivalent and then
I'm going to explain what you shouldn't
does so we're really familiar with this
one but I'll tell you what these two
means so the impulse response basically
says that the output of my system Y of T
is equal to the convolution integral so
it's a little complicated little
convoluted the convolution integral
zero to T of what do I want to call this
I'm going to call this H of t minus tau
U of tau D tau and we've actually
already seen this convolution integral
before when we were looking at this
state space system and writing X of T in
terms of the convolution of e to the a T
with bu ok so here H is an impulse
response function so if I take my system
and I give it an impulse in the control
so you can imagine let's say I have a
spring mass system and I take this thing
and I whack it with a hammer and so that
spring mass system starts ringing and
eventually dies out H of T is a function
of Y of T at directly after that impulse
directly after I hit it with a hammer
that's the response of the system
and so if I want to know what the system
does to some arbitrary input U of T some
some time varying forcing all I have to
do is convulsion integral with that
impulse response so H of T is the
impulse response
okay so I've told you that you have this
time domain representation that's
convolution with the impulse response
tells me what my output is to any
arbitrary input u that's completely
equivalent to the state space
representation I am now going to tell
you what this transfer function
representation is so that's also these
are all equivalent these are all
equivalent for a linear system and
remember the basic idea of a linear
system is that if I have two inputs if I
have u 1 and u 2 so let's say u 1 gives
rise to Y 1 and let's say u 2 gives rise
to Y 2 then what this means is that if I
add u 1 and u 2 the output is just y 1
plus y 2 and that's true for all inputs
basically so this is kind of a very
rough encapsulation of what it means to
be linear it just means that if I double
the input it doubles the output if I cut
the input in half
the output gets cut in half if I add one
input with another input the two outputs
add okay that's all it means to be
linear and for linear systems I can
choose any of these equivalent
mathematical representations for my
system for this input/output system u2y
okay I can choose state space I can
choose the impulse response framework
where I whack the system and collect
data and then I convolve that with you
or I can select this transfer function
so this is what I want to talk about for
the rest of this video is essentially
what is this transfer function and what
does it mean okay so the idea of the
transfer function is really cool what it
tells you essentially is if I put as an
input to my system let's say a sine wave
of a certain frequency for linear
systems after transients die out I
should get an output which is also a
sine wave of that exact same frequency
but it might have a bigger magnitude or
a smaller magnitude and it might be
phase shifted so let's draw a picture
okay so if so let's say I have sine
Omega T sine Omega T in then what we're
going to have out is also a sine Omega T
but it might it's hard for me to draw
the same Omega twice but it's going to
have maybe a different amplitude so I'm
going to try to draw it bigger and it
might have a different phase there might
be some phase and some amplitude okay so
this might end up being a sine Omega T
plus C okay so that's true for all
frequency sine waves into a linear
system if I take a linear system and I
force it with a sine a pure tone sine
wave at any frequency Omega the output
measurement of that linear system will
be a sine wave and it'll have the same
frequency Omega and it will have
possibly a different magnitude and
possibly some phase lead or lag but it
will be basically the same free
see sine-wave and so the transfer
function is a complex function so this
is a complex function where if I plug in
G of I Omega okay and remember e to the
I Omega is like sine Omega T or cos
Omega T plus I sine Omega T so you can
kind of imagine that if I plug in I
Omega it's like forcing this thing with
a sine wave if I look at the magnitude
of this complex number that is a the
magnitude of the output if I force this
thing with sine Omega T and if I look at
the phase angle of this complex number
so phase angle of GI Omega that's equal
to the phase of my output sine wave and
we're going to look at this in a lot
more detail we're going to look at it on
examples and make things called
frequency response curves and bode plots
so we'll go a lot more into depth but
the the idea is that if I Laplace
transform if I Laplace transform these
equations then I get this transfer
function representation in terms of a
Laplace variable f that tells me
essentially if I input different
frequencies and sines into my system how
did the output sine look is it bigger is
it smaller is its phase shifted does it
lead does it lag those are all things
that we get out of this transfer
function formulation and so a few things
that we're going to do is we're going to
actually derive this Laplace transform
expression by taking the Laplace
transform of the state space system and
we're also going to look at what it
means to plug in I Omega into this
transfer function and why I get out a
and fee and we'll talk about all of this
later and we'll also build it on an
example like the spring-mass system okay
so this is coming up but the big picture
is there are these three equivalent
representations for linear systems and
sometimes some of them are better than
others so for example if I have physics
I might want to write down an OD e and I
might want to use this to solve an l QR
or a common filter system like we did in
optimal control if I have data from an
excel
Merriman so in the olden days when
people were putting you know satellites
and spacecraft up like the Hubble or the
International Space Station what they
would do is they would build a model in
the lab so they want to know what this
thing is going to have any vibrational
modes that are going to tear it apart in
space so they'll build one in lab
they'll basically whack it with a mallet
a rubber mallet so they'll get this
impulse response and they'll see the
wave going through it and then they'll
try to use that data to back out things
like the stability properties the
eigenvalues the frequency response so if
you have lots of data you might start
from this time domain and then build out
these other models and then the reason
we're talking about transfer functions
over the next few videos is because the
transfer function perspective is
actually going to help us really
understand this balance between
robustness and performance so we're
going to be able to get a very good idea
of what robustness means by looking at
the transfer function by looking at this
complex valued transfer function G of F
of my system okay so that's where we're
going we're going to understand what the
transfer function is and then we're
going to use it to assess the robustness
of our system with with closed-loop
control okay thank you